I have a problem here
from my cousin.
Let's see what it says.
It says Milwaukee, Wisconsin
is directly west of Grand
Haven, Michigan, on opposite
sides of Lake Michigan.
So let me draw that.
So if we say that this
right here is Milwaukee.
It's due west of Grand
Haven, Michigan.
So if I were to draw-- let
me draw a horizontal line.
We're going over water so
let me do it in blue.
It's due west of Grand
Haven, Michigan.
You know, you go straight east.
If I were to go straight
east, I would get to
Grand Haven, Michigan.
Which is right here.
Let me just label that, g.
All right.
On a foggy night, a law
enforcement boat leaves
from Milwaukee on a
course of 105 degrees.
The hardest part of these
problems, in my opinion, is
really just trying to figure
out the convention
they're using.
When they say a course of 105
degrees, what does that mean?
What direction is it?
And I checked with my cousin,
and her book says that in, I
guess in the boating world,
the course is how many
degrees clockwise you're
going, of due north.
So due north is 0 degrees.
So 105 degrees.
So due north would
be 0 degrees.
Due north would be--
that's 0 degrees.
So he's going 105 degrees
clockwise of that.
So if we 105 degrees-- so
he's going 105 degrees.
So that's like 105 degrees.
Something like that.
He's going 105 degrees.
And I'll do him in magenta.
His course is 105 degrees.
So that's 105 degrees
clockwise of due north.
And what is that-- oh, it's
like my screen just backed up.
So what is that angle, in kind
of what we're familiar with?
Well, this would be 90
degrees right here.
Going here.
And then he goes
15 more degrees.
So in kind of unit circle
terms, this would be
negative 15 degrees.
Or if we wanted to figure out
the angle of this vertex right
here, that would be 90, and
then we'd go another 15.
So this angle right here
is going to be what?
It's going to be 15 degrees.
Because he said his
course is 105.
So 90 plus 15 is 105.
So how much south he's going
of, kind of, straight
west-east, is 15 degrees.
This whole thing is 105.
OK, let me keep
reading the problem.
He leaves from Milwaukee at a
course of 105 degrees at the
same time that a small
smuggling craft steers a
course of 195 degrees
from Grand Haven.
195 degrees.
So once again, due
north is 0 degrees.
And this guy's going 195.
So we figure-- this is
just a convention.
You figure out-- well,
he's going 195 degrees
clockwise of due north.
So 195 degrees is going to be--
let's see, it's going to be
a 180 degrees and then some.
It's going to be like that.
So his course is going to
look something like this.
His course is going to
look something like that.
And let's see if we can
figure out what this
angle right here is.
Because we, as you can kind of
see where this is going, we're
trying to figure out probably
the size of this triangle,
if I had to guess.
I haven't even read the
whole problem yet.
Let's see.
So he's going 195 degrees.
So if we were to drop,
well, like here.
This right here is a 180
degrees, to go clockwise from
straight up to straight down.
This is 180.
And so he went 195.
So this is going to be-- that's
going to be 15 degrees.
And if this angle is 15
degrees, what is this
angle going to be?
Well, this entire angle
is 90 degrees, right?
It's kind of the third
quadrant when we're thinking
in unit circle terms.
So this angle right
here is going to be 90
minus this 15 degrees.
So what's 90 minus 15?
It's 75, right?
75 degrees.
And if we wanted to convert
his, kind of, course angles
into unit circles-- you know,
with unit circles, you start
here and you go all the
way around this way.
So I think you would get
something like 255 degrees.
But anyway.
So we figured out that this
angle is 15 degrees, this
angle is 75 degrees.
What's this angle going to be?
This angle is going to be--
these all have to add
up to 180, right?
So this is going to be
180 minus 15 minus 75.
And what's that?
That's 180 minus 90.
So 180 minus 90 is 90 degrees!
So this angle here
is 90 degrees.
It's a right angle.
Interesting.
OK, so what do they tell us?
They tell us the law
enforcement boat
averages 23 knots.
So he's traveling in this
direction at 23 knots.
All right, that's a little bit
faster than 23 miles per hour.
And collides with the
smuggling craft.
What was the smuggling
boat's average speed?
So they both leave their
respective sites at the
same time, and they
both collide, right?
So the time they
traveled is the same.
Let's call that time, t.
Right?
I don't know.
They both left at the same
time and it took some
time for them to collide.
So let's say that the time
between when they left and
the time they collided is t.
So how far did the
patrol boat travel?
Well, he traveled at a speed of
23 knots, and it took him time,
t, to get to the collision.
So the distance he
traveled is 23t.
Speed times time is
equal to distance.
So the length of
this side is 23t.
Similarly, this guy, we
don't know his speed.
Let's call it, I don't know.
Let's call it x.
His speed is x.
But the distance he
travels is x times t.
x times t, right?
So that's the length
of this side.
So let's see if we can
figure out what x is.
So what do we know?
We know a lot about this.
We know this is a right
triangle, et cetera.
We know this angle.
So if we wanted to solve
for xt and use this 23t
information, let's see.
We know-- look at this angle.
If we use the 75 degrees, we
know the opposite angle.
The opposite side, sorry.
Which is 23t.
And we know the adjacent
side, which is xt.
So let me write SOHCAHTOA here.
So what deals with
opposite and adjacent?
Well, that's tangent, right?
TOA.
So if we say the tan of 75
degrees is going to be equal to
the opposite side-- 23t-- over
the adjacent side-- that's this
side, opposite over
adjacent-- xt.
Well, the t's
cancel out, right?
The t's cancel out.
And let's see if we
can solve for x.
Multiply x times both sides.
You get x tangent of
75 is equal to 23.
And then divide both sides by
the tan of 75 and you get x is
equal to 23 divided by the
tangent of 75 degrees.
And so that's our answer.
And if I had to-- well,
actually, I have-- let's see.
Tangent of 75 degrees.
I don't have a calculator
in front of me.
You could calculate it.
It's actually going to be
a pretty high number.
So you could try
to fit, you know.
If you have a calculator,
just type in 75 degrees.
Take the tangent of it, and
perform this calculation.
But we've essentially
solved this problem.
I'll see you in the next video.